you
my name is Adrian Smith I'm a British
veterinarian I've been resident in
Norway for the last 35 years I work his
secretary for the Norwegian Center for
the replacement reduction and refinement
of animal experiments which is called
Nora Kouba i would like to present Nora
cobas website which is the result of
many years collaboration with both the
norwegian school of veterinary science
in oslo and the animal welfare
information centre a week which is part
of the US National Agricultural library
facilities in Beltsville Maryland the
need for easy access to quality
controlled species and situation
specific guidelines for animal research
has never been greater and the media are
now overflowing with animal related
material much of which is not
particularly selected or peer-reviewed
indeed the advent of powerful search
engines can give the impression that it
is no longer necessary to involve
professional information specialists but
recent scientific papers have revealed
poor reproducibility and translate
ability of animal studies week
experimental design indications of
inadequate postoperative analgesia and
lack of compliance with guidelines for
reporting animal studies so we believe
scientists need easy access to quality 3
our resources and the ability to
document the soldier sort searches which
they have performed so with this in mind
Nora Kouba has built a big relational
database of three our resources coupled
to an intelligent search engine tunes to
the field of laboratory animal science
the website address is easy to remember
Nora called the dot mo
Nora Kouba website consists a day of for
databases and web pages within the watch
Animal Science welfare and alternatives
a total of about 5,000 pages the content
of the website has been hand-picked to
display the best quality resources
within the field the website provides
information of use to all those who plan
conduct or evaluate animal research
those information on guidelines
legislation databases three are
alternatives education and training
materials including films of common
procedures and animals and lists of
journals email discussion forums and
organizations the website contains
nearly 23,000 unique links and we have
installed an automated module that
checks the sites for broken links to
help you find the resources you're
looking for we have installed a
tailor-made intelligent search engine
with a mile things a synonym list
especially written for lab animal
science a nullity number of search
filters can be applied all removed
dynamically to increase the relevance of
your search results all searches and
their filters generate unique web
addresses or URLs making it easy to
document and repeat the searches that
you've performed normally khobor also
maintains an international meetings
calendar on the website and a newsfeed
about European lab animal news we also
issue a newsletter eight to nine times a
year this is currently in Norwegian but
we have subscribers from abroad and we
are considering issuing an English
version as well we
you'll find that the website is relevant
to your work whether you're a scientist
animal technologist all involved in the
ethics and regulation of animal research
thank you for listening if you have any
questions about Nora Cooper's website or
its activities please feel free to
contact us by email